[Music]
what's up everyone
this is disney plus deets where we break
down everything you need to know about
your favorite disney plus movies and
series
i'm kenneth and i'm marcellus and not to
toot our own horns but we're pretty much
the biggest disney plus fans out there
no let's do it
that's right let's get into it
[Music]
today we're telling you what you need to
know and what you maybe didn't know
about marvel studios
guardians of the galaxy yes this film is
full of adventure
action and comedy uh-huh this movie
always cracks me up okay let's start
with the background kick us off my salad
you got it okay pay attention
this film features the guardians team
that first appeared in guardians of the
galaxy vol
2 issue 1 in 2008 yes however
they were not the first guardians of the
galaxy team comic readers met the
original guardians in marvel superheroes
issue 18 all the way back in 1969.
well did you know that the set for the
milano took 14 weeks to build
james gunn wanted quill's environment to
be reminiscent of earth
he wanted it to be mechanical with comb
and leather and have a muscle car look
well he succeeded i love it
uh-oh oh wait a minute why did he leave
at the hospital
and nobody watching him he was going
through it ken he was like all that just
went on he's running he's like missing
his mom
i said this is something you would have
done you would arrange all the hospitals
where you are somewhere else now we see
him wearing a backpack and
this inspired the art department to kind
of pepper the interior of the milano
with more artifacts from his childhood
you can see stickers and baseball cards
dolls and other fun details throughout
the ship
i am groot i love groovy i'm honest with
you
i really love where he might be able to
give me some advice on my plan and they
keep dying
did you know vin diesel said groot
having only that one line of dialogue
sold him on playing the character
can you imagine hey then you want to be
in this movie you only have to say one
line
yeah except he had to record it over a
thousand times i wonder people forgot
his line
uh uh diesel
also recorded all his lines in german
russian
french portuguese mandarin spanish and
other languages so that groot would
feature his voice all around the world
oh my god i would love to have my voice
heard all around the world
i'm sure you would ken but with the
world love it
strike one rocket is voiced by the great
bradley cooper
but he was actually not on set james
gunn's brother
sean gunn who also played craiglin in
the film
was the stand-in during filming ken you
could have been the stand-in you and
rocket are about the same height
moving on look at her look at it she's
looking like i'm gonna get that orb by
the way i love how she's just chilling
chilling chilling and then she's like
yoink
right right right got it gamora's look
for this movie took up the five
hours in hair and makeup flawless she
looks great
it's like perfectly done i love it zoe
saldana we honor you
oh you are obsessed with amazing here we
go
the filmmakers built several large-scale
sets for the film
and the kiln the space prison where the
guardians meet was the largest build of
all
get this the kiln set was designed in
360 degrees
and made up of 350 thousand pounds of
steel across
three levels and they extended the set
by 200 feet in post production
i love that
there he is there he is i love drax
he's played by dave bautista who did you
know as a former professional wrestler
not only is he the longest reigning
world heavyweight champion
in wwe history but he's also a great
actor
james gunn praised batista's ability to
tap into drake's raw emotion
he is exactly what gun imagined for
draft we've got to talk about his makeup
design ken
drax's life story is told through his
tattoos and scarification
this process took four hours a day
bautista actually
stood during most of those four hours
okay i can't even stand 30 minutes at
the dmv
same it took a team of five makeup
artists and 18 prosthetic pieces for the
body and face
by the end of production bautista had
spent nearly seven entire days in a
makeup chair
oh i can't wait for my glam team you
know if i was in this prison i think i
would be like turquoise that'd be my
color
anyway i love when actors are committed
to their role karen gillian was so
committed to playing nebula that she
shaved her head
and it was a great move flawless oh
here's the collector's lap
it is filled with artifacts from all
over the marvel cinematic universe
the filmmakers use this as an
opportunity to fill his lab with easter
eggs
you can find dark ales from for the dark
world the reality stone
the tesseract a chatauri soldier from
the avengers
cosmo the space dog from the ussr space
program
and even howard the duck wait did you
know that howard the duck is voiced by
seth green
in this movie oh i love these details
what else should we talk about well we
gotta talk about the music
[Music]
this soundtrack is amazing the props
department scoured the internet for
months trying to track down the perfect
cassette player for peter's character
and could only find 16 that would be
suitable to use in the film i remember
my cassette player
that was cutting edge technology at the
time during production
james gunn had the sound department play
both the film's score
and the tracks from peter cool's
playlist on set i love the soundtrack
so fun the soundtrack makes me want to
dance i don't even know how that got
anything done it would just be constant
dance party oh i gotta dance now let's
drop this up and get some music going
listen this movie is so exciting it was
just a beautiful
joy to watch on the screen come on
marzella's on your feet
i guess that's our show folks check out
marvel studios guardians of the galaxy
now streaming on disney plus
take care of yourselves and the planet
and make sure to subscribe and like this
video marcelo where are you at
i'm coming i'm coming okay marcellus and
ken signing off